hey youtubers it's Charlie big channel
and life updates that I wanted to tell
you guys about don't worry everything is
good news I wanted to do this special
video just because I already do so many
other videos and you know when it
doesn't have anything to do with dragons
and zombies spaceships or Time Lords
it's kind of hard to squeeze in so
here's what I'm gonna do first I'm gonna
tell you about the big changes that are
going on with the videos I'm doing you
know what's happening what's going to be
happening real soon
especially the physical changes that are
happening on YouTube right now because
typically things change every couple
months then second I'll talk about some
of the big changes going on behind the
scenes in my real life you know some of
the big things that are gonna be
happening this year that I'm doing just
to make it easier for me to do it I love
would just make videos and hang out with
you guys and then just because I totally
don't talk about it enough I'm gonna
tell you about some youtubers that I'm
really excited about right now as well
as conventions and YouTube related stuff
that I'm gonna be doing in the next
couple of months
I feel like eventually I should probably
create a vlog channel for stuff like
this
but until my dream of becoming a space
pirate comes true I'll just squeeze it
in on emergency awesome every once in a
while so here we go starting with new
videos that I'm working on right now
this weekend is the Walking Dead finale
which is gonna be amazing so if you're
not quite caught up I recommend you
binge watch on Netflix they have
everything up to season four AMC is also
running a marathon of season 4 episodes
just so you can fill that gap everything
else I do Doctor Who arrow Marvel agents
of shield and so on is staying the same
no changes there but Game of Thrones is
coming back April 6th that's next Sunday
the Sunday after this coming Sunday so
it's gonna happen is those videos will
take the place of the Walking Dead
videos I would normally be doing I'll
still be doing bonus videos for Walking
Dead just like I do for all the other
favorite shows and the off season so if
there is a particular type of bonus
video that you want to see just leave me
suggestions in the comments below in
addition to swapping Sunday's Walking
Dead for Game of Thrones videos I'm
gonna be carrying my weekly giveaway
over so since there's 10 episodes of
Game of Thrones - this season there'll
be 10 more weeks of the giveaway onto
big YouTube changes so YouTube changes
the platform every couple of months so
the way it looks and the way it shows
you new videos that I've posted so here
are some details about what's changed
and how to fix that most of the time
every
works great but every once in a while
it's a total epic fail so here are a
couple things you can do just to make
sure you don't miss out on giveaways or
new videos I post right now there are
two different YouTube layouts that you
guys might be seeing but YouTube calls
this home page the guide this is where
most do you see my new videos show up so
all you have to do is go to the my
subscriptions tab which depending on
your layout is over here on the left
hand side or up at the top of the home
page inside your subscriptions page you
can just mouse over one of my videos and
select get an email for each upload from
emergency awesome I typically post about
ten videos a week so this is the only
way to guarantee that you don't miss
stuff it'll just send you an email
whenever I post a new video I know a lot
of you are international so there's a
huge timezone difference and sometimes I
end up posting videos while you're
asleep and as much as YouTube does weird
things to change how everything looks
this is actually one feature that is
really amazing so just as an example I
subscribe to about you know 30 some-odd
channels but I really like vlogbrothers
you know Hank and John Green's dftba
stuff so I enable email alerts for their
stuff and just keep everything else on
default there is the tried-and-true sit
on the videos page and just you know
refresh the channel to wait til someone
post a new video but personally I just
recommend you enable email alerts and
save yourself the time if you're not a
big email person or you just want to
talk to me offline
there's always social media so I'm most
active on Twitter Facebook Tumblr
Instagram and Google+ here's the links
for all those accounts there's also
links at the top of my channel page here
I wasn't able to fit my entire name on
Twitter so that's a little different but
for the most part I'm emergency awesome
on all these different platforms so if
it's the middle of the day and you just
want to say hi you can always tweet at
me or post on my Facebook page I read
all the YouTube comments but here's
where I need to mention Google+ because
that does kind of affect how the
comments show up so if you haven't heard
about it yet Google created this thing
called top fans it's just a way for
channels like mine that are getting
really big to you know help communicate
with the most active engagers they just
you know people that want to talk to me
the most you know comment the most watch
the most videos in the future I'll
actually
doing some special giveaways and
hangouts as well as maybe some free
t-shirts for this group of people right
now there's about 5,000 of you in it the
easiest way to jump to the top of that
list because Google does it internally
it's not something I do manually is to
just follow me on Google+ and usually it
kind of kicks you into that system
I do like Google+ but really it's mostly
helpful for just managing comments and
also because of the changes now if you
want to make sure that I see your
comment all you have to do is add the
plus symbol in front of my name whenever
you leave a comment and it will you know
mention me it's like mentioning someone
on Twitter you know I still read all the
comments on videos no matter what so I
will still see what you have to say but
whenever you add a plus it sends your
comment directly to my gmail inbox so
that pretty much covers all the big
changes to YouTube as well as you know
social accounts to help fill the gaps
whenever things go wrong on YouTube
so onto big changes in my personal life
I am still currently working a full-time
job I might be turning full-time creator
by the end of the year that would
definitely be my dream to just make
youtube videos and hang out with you
guys all day long for a living that
would be amazing but I'll be sure and
let you guys know if that happens before
the end of the year because we will be
popping bottles in the short-term I'm
still looking for a new apartment I have
to relocate the TARDIS somewhere just a
little bit bigger so that I can make it
easier to shoot YouTube videos probably
sometime this summer before Comic Con
I'll be sure to do a bigger on the
inside room tour once I get everything
set up I will be getting some extra
camera gear that'll make it a little bit
easier to do live streams but there's a
lot of technical stuff involved so for
example during the fall you might see me
do live Doctor Who and Walking Dead
videos which I'm really excited to try
so if you have any questions about the
videos I'm working on or stuff that's
coming up or stuff that's happening in
my life you know just leave it in the
comments below or just send me a
high-five on Twitter on the other hand
if you are just finding me for the first
time and you have no idea what's going
on be sure to subscribe below to get all
my stuff
there will be dragons coming next week
it's gonna be awesome
also here's details on some of the
conventions that I'm gonna be at this
summer as well as you know other
youtubers that I'm really excited about
right now I will be at WonderCon at the
end of April VidCon at the end of June
and then I'll be at Comic Con at the end
of July I might also be doing a comic
panel but I don't know what's happening
with that so I'll post updates whenever
it's all figured out my favorite
youtubers right now though whenever I'm
not working on my own videos are Hank
and John Green
you know most of all they're
vlogbrothers stuff I love but I also
subscribe to all their dftba channels
like scishow and the new scishow space
channel that they're making
then there's Vsauce with Michael I
actually used to work with him on barely
political videos way back in the early
days of YouTube I dare you to try and
find some of them for video game stuff
I'm a huge fan of pewds
just like the rest of the world
obviously but also smaller creators like
Dodger on dexterity bonus and her press
our channels tons of fun to watch you
should check them out so I hope you
enjoyed all my updates if you have any
questions again just leave them below in
the comments right now click here to see
all my final Walking Dead predictions
finales happening on Sunday and you can
click here to catch up on Game of
Thrones before next week because dragons
are coming and it's gonna be so much fun
thanks so much for watching guys I'll
see you tomorrow high fives